diversity programs are designed to
promote inclusivity and to promote
understanding among different cultures
and communities the Wright loves to say
that those programs actually suppress
speech bully people
Etc to the extent that you give me an
example of that I am on your side and I
will be against it you all know if
you've been listening to this program
for a while that I don't go for that
stuff when the left goes too far as the
right loves to say I'll just tell you
yeah I don't agree with this this is not
in the spirit of progressivism this is
not in the spirit of
um uh libertarian progressivism of the
style that I and so many other
Progressive support those instances are
relatively rare and when you say no
diversity programs whatsoever you're
Banning programs that actually provide
significant value and they promote
understanding among different groups in
a way that is completely not it's not
only harmless it's a positive thing
um this is what Florida Republicans are
now focused on